nous accueillons aujourd'hui amalia
d'aden et yacine chibane deux
ergothérapeutes diplômé de l'université
de montréal et qui exercent leur métier
dans la même ville bonjour canada des
névroses origine cubaine
alors à vous de vous est récipiendaire
de la bourse de la fondation club à
venir pour la réalisation d'une étude
sur l' équilibre de vie ou ce que vous
appelez équilibre occupationnel chez les
maghrébins établis au canada et vous
êtes intéressé particulièrement aux
algériens dans la région de montréal
avant d'aller plus loin on voudrait bien
que ceux qui ne suce comprennent ce que
c'est qu'être au thérapeute donc c'est
quoi être temps de vous une explication
que monsieur et madame tout le monde
puisse comprendre oui merci
c'est sûr que quand on parle d'art
thérapie beaucoup de personnes savent
pas c'est quoi
on fait un beau thérapeute c'est un
professionnel de la santé qui vise à
maintenir et à améliorer l'autonomie de
la personne dans ses activités activités
c'est un thème vraiment très vaste et en
fait c'est ce serait renier à des
diagnostics possible qu'admettant
quelqu'un qui aurait un problème au
niveau de la santé physique ou quelqu'un
qui aurait un problème au niveau de la
santé mentale qui peut pas faire ces
activités comme avant donc quelqu'un qui
est paralysé par exemple ne va pas
pouvoir se faire cette activité comme
avant il va falloir réapprendre à sortir
et rentrer dans le lit réapprendre à
s'habiller réapprendre à utiliser la
salle de bains dans l'herbe au
thérapeute est vraiment là pour ça et en
santé mentale on pouvait penser à
quelqu'un qui fait une dépression et qui
appartenait au travail dans l'argot
thérapeute à travers avec la personne
pour un retour au travail premier si je
peux ajouter je pourrais être impliqué
auprès de merck aux thérapeutes il faut
être en situation de handicap
donc toutes les diagnostics que yasmina
nomique que ce soit au niveau physique
mental affectif que ce soit au niveau
cognitif
ça va impliquer des barrières qui vont
affecter la réalisation des activités et
donc là c'est la personne en situation
d'handicap
donc c'est là que le rôle de l'herbe ou
intervenir et comment je compte devient
un ergothérapeute
en fait après des études en sciences de
la santé au cégep donc un deck
préuniversitaire il faut s'inscrire pour
faire un baccalauréat plus une maîtrise
professionnelle en ergothérapie donc
selon l'université à l'université de
montréal c'est un baccalauréat en
ergothérapie suivi d'une maîtrise en
albite est rapide mais dans d'autres
universités comme par exemple à
l'université mcgill ont pu faire bac en
sciences de la santé et ensuite
s'inscrire à la maîtrise en à côté
rapide pour être éligibles à être
inscrits à l'autre et dans votre métier
qui encadrés par un professionnel quand
vous venez de mentionner
on parle beaucoup de l' équilibre de vie
où l'équilibré occupationnel pour moi
c'est des choses qu'on peut pas mesurer
pour moi quand on vit on peut on peut
planifier ses finances mais vous arrivez
à dire que ouais je suis bien dans ma
peau je peux mesurer ça c'est la
difficulté avec ça gros que vous y
arrivez vous à léquilibre de vie c'est
un concept qui est vraiment important à
notre profession parce que des impôts
thérapeute crois fondamentalement que
les activités permettent d'organiser le
quotidien d'une personne permettent de
donner un sens et une signification à la
vie et donc un équilibre de vie ce
serait un équilibre entre toutes les
activités qu'une personne fait que ce
soit des activités productives que ce
soit des activités de loisirs que ce
soit des activités de repos que ce soit
des activités sociales donc un équilibre
de vie c'est vraiment un amalgame
d'activité et on le mesure bien
évidemment souvent par des
questionnaires standardisés ou le plus
le meilleur outil qu'on a et le
questionnement qui l'entrevue avec le
patient même si je peux juste d'ajouter
dans le fond de relations dont les
données probantes et prouver que
l'équilibré occupationnel c'est un
facteur de santé donc plus une personne
va avoir un meilleur équilibre
occupationnel comme yasmina expliqué
puis elle va être en bonne santé
donc à partir de ce moment nous on pense
en amont de la maladie donc avant même
d'arriver à parler de maladie mentale de
stress de maladies physiques combat en
amont il équilibre occupationnel c'est
un facteur déterminant sur lequel on
peut agir pour faire de la prévention
donc c'est là que tout le sens au niveau
de la santé rapport est ce qu'il s'agit
de de réussir sa vie professionnelle ou
bien d'être en bon
son défi physique ou mentale ou où
est-ce que celle amalgame de tout ce qui
en fait une chose qui est importante à
garder en tête c'est que l' équilibre de
vie c'est aussi quelque chose de très
personnel donc entre moi qui aime elle
peut-être que ce qu'on conçoit comme
équilibre de vie est différent
peut-être que je mets plus d'importance
au niveau des activités de productivité
dans mon travail ma carrière et elle
mais la lame bien faire de l'art est
donc l homme intègre et des activités de
loisirs dans son quotidien
donc c'est propre à chacun et à partir
de là vous êtes par les sabres une étude
sur la communauté algérienne qui vit ici
au canada
bien sûr vous êtes intéressé à cette
demande en quoi a consisté votre étude
met donc les objectifs de notre étude
c'était vraiment de documenter le
phénomène de l'equilibre occupationnel
fichiers la communauté algérienne de
marianne dans le fond nous on est clean
i scène 1 go thérapeute
on a on s'est posé des questions à
travers notre pratique mais on a
remarqué qu'il y avait certaines idées
préconçues
par rapport à cette population là et que
y existait peu de littérature presque
pas de littérature sur les besoins de
cette communauté
donc à partir de là on s'est posé des
questions est ce qu'on a voulu faire
c'est vraiment documenté l'équilibré
occupationnel et tous les facteurs qui
peuvent l'influencer
pour commencer dans le fond semer une
graine au niveau de la littérature avoir
déjà un premier pas qui se fait pour
mieux comprendre cette communauté donc
les objectifs spécifiques c'était
vraiment de comprendre l'équilibré
personnel documenter les facteurs le
stress à ceux ci est d'aller plus en
profondeur avec des entrevues
qu'est-ce qui s'est dégagée de cette
étude si je pourrais juste rajouter avec
quelques points en fait notre étude
s'est fait en deux temps
on avait l'étude 1 qui était un cas qui
étaient en fait deux questionnaires
standardisés et ont réussi 23
participants et danser en fait 123
personnes ont répondu à un questionnaire
qu'on utilise en clinique qui est un
questionnaire qui mesure le niveau d'
équilibre de vie
donc en fait la personne réponde et si
oui ou non il faisait une activité et
s'ils souhaiteraient
faire davantage ou enfer mois et on a
également utilisé un questionnaire sur
le stress perçu donc où la personne
répondait à quatre échelles pour dire en
fait indiqué si elle était stressée ou
non et en deuxième temps en fait on a
fait des entrevues
donc on a choisi des participants qui
correspondait à des profils distincts
pour avoir une variété de réponses et
venez poser des questions pour avoir un
regard plus qualitatif qu'est-ce qui
s'est dégagée de tout ça donc en fait
étant donné que notre étude était très
vaste
on a également étudié cinq facteurs
différents en lien avec l'équilibré de
vie et le stress perçu donc les cinq
facteurs qu'on a choisi était le genre
l'âge le revenu on avait quoi d'autre la
catégorie d'emploi et l'état matrimonial
donc c'est sûr que ça nous a donné une
grande richesse d'informations si je
peux emmener quelques heures ce qui en
est ressorti c'est que les jeunes de 20
à 24 ans ont souvent indiqué qu'ils
avaient un niveau d'équilibré moindre et
un stress perçu plus élevé donc ça
pouvait nous permettre d'émettre des
hypothèses que c'est souvent à cet âge
là qu'on commence à découvrir la vie
adulte et que aussi en prend beaucoup de
décisions par rapport à notre avenir que
ce soit l'entrée à l'université le choix
d'université et c'est aussi le moment de
commencer à affirmer son autonomie
on a eu aussi au niveau du revenu ça
c'est un résultat qui ne nous surprend
pas mais habituellement les gens qui ont
un moindre revenu en niveau d' équilibre
plus basse était c'est normal en a moins
de thor pour passer à sur nos loisirs
sur les activités de repos et donc c'est
sûr que ces personnes vont avoir un
niveau d'équilibré
- juste avant l' équilibre moindrot plus
c'est la personne qui le définissait pas
celle équilibre perdu donc la
satisfaction de la personne par rapport
à une activité donc par exemple on a une
question dans notre dans le
questionnaire qui dit est-ce que vous
pratiquez une activité
je me rappelle plus de couture ou peuple
donc on est d'accord que c'est une
activité que peut-être nous intéresse
pas tout le monde donc lisible la
personne n'est pas
rey s'est elle n'est pas au déséquilibre
parce qu'elle fait pas du tricote je
sais pas une façon de c'est vraiment par
rapport à sa satisfaction personnelle
mais par exemple si on a une question
qui demande à la personne
est-ce que vous passez du temps sur les
écrans et que la personne répond plus
que ce que je voudrais là ça veut dire
qu elle est en déséquilibre
parce que c'est pas c'est parce qu'ils
eussent qu'il a satisfait la personne
aurait voulu passer moins de temps sur
les écrans
pardon parce que moment j'avais peur que
que vous avez un moule et que si la
personne ne rentre pas dans ce moule
donc elle est déséquilibré finalement
non c'est vraiment un rapport et mais
d'après ce votre description pour moi ça
simplement spécifique aux communautés à
une autre ça c'est ce monsieur ou madame
tout le monde qui peut avoir ce genre de
dangereux alors pourquoi c'est si on
cherchait spécifiquement dans une
communauté
en fait on a réalisé que il existe très
peu de données sur la communauté
algérienne et on voulait voir est ce
qu'il y à bien les biens des différents
sont à communauté algérienne et le reste
des populations et ce qui est on est
ressorti c'est que oui en fait la
population algérienne à montréal est
davantage stressé que les moyennes
générales et présent effectivement un
certain niveau de déséquilibre
occupationnel est donc pour nous c'est
une réalité que les cliniciens devrait
prendre en compte lors de leurs
interventions avec leur passion
effectivement dans dans l'optique dans
le fond les cliniciens de développer une
pratique clinique qui est plus sensible
culturellement et avoir de meilleures
compétences au niveau de cette clientèle
parce qu'on est d'accord que la
clientèle maghrébine à montréal prend de
plus en plus d'ampleur et présent des
besoins qui sont spécifiques à elle même
donc pour les cliniciens c'est important
d'être au courant de leurs besoins et
donc d'adapter le ratent leur approche
donne moi un exemple de spécificité par
rapport à l'équipe à léquilibre
occupation d horreur pour quelqu'un de
la comaga maghrébine en algérie ben
justement ça c'était l'objet de l'étude
deux donc les entrevues qualitatif c'est
un peu ça qu'ils auraient révélé
donc dans le fond la communauté
algérienne quand on leur pose la
question sur l' équilibre de vie
théoriquement ils ont les bonnes
connaissances ils savent en théorie
c'est quoi avoir un bon équilibre de vie
par contre pour adopter les bonnes
stratégies efficaces il ya quelques
obstacles qui se présentent dans
l'environnement que ce soit au niveau de
la culture les valeurs des fois c'est
juste au niveau des personnes même par
exemple il ya plusieurs personnes dans
les entrevues qui nous ont parlé d'une
mauvaise gestion du temps en lien avec
les églises les églises en les exigences
d'ici aussi ils nous ont parlé d'une
banalisation niveau de la santé mentale
on banalise l'effet que peut avoir la
surcharge sur notre mental aussi ça peut
avoir l'air très banales mais par
exemple
l'adaptation au climat ça fait en sorte
qu' il y en a que pour eux juste trouver
des activités à faire l'hiver ça les
plonge dans un déséquilibre
occupationnel total ils font aucun
loisir
donc c'est des réalités auxquelles il
faut être au courant pour avoir une
meilleure sensibilité parce que ce n'est
pas la même chose que la population
générale
alors tous ces résultats peuvent être
utilisés ailleurs alors comment est-ce
qu'on peut utiliser cette étude et vos
résultats
est ce que pourrait être récupéré par
une autre équipe ou bien donnerait lieu
à des activités bien précises comme on
pourrait voir cette étude ailleurs
contre vos mains donc bien sûr le but de
cette étude on voulait premièrement que
ce soit à titre indicatif
donc pour pouvoir renseigner les gens
par rapport aux problématiques que les
algériens rencontre mais étant donné
qu'on est à vos thérapeute on voulait
également outiller la population qu'on a
étudié et donc un mal et moi allons
monter un atelier où est ce qu'on va
donner des recommandations pour parvenir
à avoir un meilleur équilibre de vie
donc ça c'est la première portait en
fait de notre étude
on pourrait s'attendre que dans les
prochaines semaines après la publication
de leurs résultats que compte qu'on
trouve que vous allez organiser des
ateliers tout ça donc exact écoutez nous
vous demanderons de nous tenir au
courant de ça est-ce que vous avez
quelque chose à rajouter
juste par rapport à l'étude c'est sûr
que c'est pas une étude qui est
subventionné par un centre de recherche
universitaire donc on peut pas vraiment
utiliser l'étude puisque ya pas de
comité éthique approuvé le projet au
niveau d'un centre hospitalier
universitaire par contre ça sème une
graine dans le monde
les données probantes parce que c'est
vraiment une étude existait auparavant
par rapport à cet âge là pour cette
communauté
donc nous aussi à travers nos réseaux
sociaux à travers nos réseaux
professionnels on va partager un peu
d'informations et sensibiliser nos
collègues à ces résultats nous vivons la
pandémie depuis mars et le confinement
puis le déconfinement et pileux à moitié
confinement comment commence à influer
sur la sur l' équilibre équilibre de
ville soit de chez les maghrébins ou jeu
chez la population générale
est-ce que cela a des incidences donc
dans le fond dans les entrevues on a pu
un peu se pencher sur cet aspect là c
est ressortie par rapport à certains
groupes de la population la cage vide
commencent à influencer encore plus à
exacerber en fait le problème qui
existait déjà de déséquilibre donc par
exemple chez les étudiants se retrouver
dans sa chambre être en isolement ne pas
voir son réseau social être en surcharge
de travail mais seul devant son
ordinateur amène beaucoup de stresser et
je dirais même de cet homme dépressif de
la génération par exemple de mon père
les hommes dans la cinquantaine qui
travaillent qui ont un travail stable
qui font du télétravail ça ne les
affecte pas autant puisqu'il ya quand
même une certaine stabilité dans leur
horaire donc à part le fait que si à la
maison mais ça ça change pas alors que
les étudiants qui sont habitués à une
vie beaucoup plus dynamique d'aller à
l'université de rencontrer leurs
collègues ça les affecte
et puis moi je rajouterais un petit peu
un regard au niveau des hôpitaux en fait
je
j'ai travaillé en gériatrie puis
maintenant on leur projet on a remarqué
que chez les personnes âgées
il ya eu quand même davantage
d'hospitalisations et des personnes qui
étaient davantage mal en point à cause
de l' isolement et le fait d'être seul
et n'avoir personne qui vient les voir
il ya beaucoup de personnes âgées qui
ont fait des delirium et qui ont dû se
retrouver à être hospitalisé parce qu'il
n'était plus sécuritaire tout seul à
domicile donc en fait cet isolement là
ce confinement là malgré le fait qu'on
veut protéger les personnes âgées et
bien à une conséquence également sur eux
edit mans vous dernière question là
quand vous constatez ça est-ce que vous
pouvez intervenir par exemple dans le
cas des étudiants qu'est ce que vous
leur conseiller dans le cas des
personnes âgées que ce que vous leur
conseiller oui mais pour les
fondamentaux de la clientèle c'est sûr
qu'il ya des stratégies qui peuvent être
adaptés par exemple à la maison les
étudiants adoptée tout les bons princes
et ergonomique juste de bien être
installé sur son bureau puisqu'il passe
beaucoup de temps au bureau juste
d'avoir une bonne posture d'avoir une
bonne bon environnement de travail de
prendre des poses de se doter d'une
stratégie de travail donc par 50 minutes
de travail ensuite prendre une pause
faire des check list est que toutes
sortes d'outils mais l'essentiel se
trouver les outils qui sont les plus
efficaces pour soi même et qui répondent
à nos besoins et pour les populations
hospitalisé bien sûr que quand on
travaille avec eux pour la réadaptation
on souhaite les amis un niveau
d'autonomie voit ce qu'ils vont être
sécuritaire à la maison il ya des
limites à ce qu'on peut faire parce
qu'on ne peut pas forcément aller à
domicile mais il ya vraiment eu je
trouve des organismes communautaires qui
font du bon travail il ya des bénévoles
qui font des appels chez les personnes
âgées comme des des worlds checks des
trucs comme ça donc sans être uniquement
la responsabilité du système de santé il
ya également des mesures communautaires
qui sont en train de monter puis je
trouve c'est très important
or merci amalia d'adèle et merci à
signer chibane je rappelle que vous êtes
deux offres aux thérapeutes qui exerce à
montréal merci d'avoir participé entre
édition merci beaucoup